hey guys I'm Ryan right hi I'm Jerry and
tonight we're gonna watch the trailer
for Metal Gear salt Meryl five buzzer
yeah Meryl Metal Gear Solid Meryl snake
I only played up to Metal Gear Solid 3 I
never played part four so I don't
actually know for five is gonna be about
I played a few minutes apart for it is a
really loud day in your neighbor it's a
loud name my neighbor there's like a
mariachi band playing very loud and lots
of sirens yeah dude yeah it's it's loud
today and you know what I kind of like a
loud yeah it's my [ __ ] [ __ ] it gets
loud up in this [ __ ] need something to
tune out the noise you know what I mean
yeah so the neighbors no complain my
[ __ ] screaming the head off
Oh Ryan you're so sexy Oh mommy come in
look at that ass for you but it should
call you mommy
no not just a nickname she gives me okay
whatever ma'am sorry she's the way
Lauren talks anyway yeah no I love here
I really do love it even though I
haven't played part for it I just didn't
have the money at the time to get a PS
warrant never got around to it cuz now
I'm loaded with money so I could but
anytime cocky joke yeah I never got
around to playing part four but trust me
I was addicted to the first three like I
played them all multiple times we would
go to school talk about you got me
something yeah that's right I got you
into it just like I got you in anal yeah
that's now necessarily gonna happen is
it I not my bag keep trying but you did
get me in the middle gear solid I got a
PlayStation 2 partly because of that I
think dude man metal your saw was bomber
metal gear saw wouldn't you were rest to
you okay mg has to like solidified it
but mgs1 was this like that changed
everything forever for me like watching
that as a little kid where he's like
knocking on the wall and then they're
like huh someone's good you know and
then sneak up behind them there's like a
sneaking so it's like a real survival
game it was a first like real movie game
too and the Miller saw to is like hey
remember everything you loved about part
one but it improve the quality out of
everything by like a million it's like
we're gonna get the mouse's time and the
graphics still stand and then they then
they remade they did snake they did
whatever that when snakes
twin snakes yeah for gamecube when they
read a play that was awesome like I
honestly preferred the original piece
PlayStation 1 I'm not doing that to be
like a cocky like
hey it was better when it was just the
original but what you grew up on that
there is that sort of like you know you
have a more emotional attachment to
those more actually because Metal Gear
Solid 2 they and they allow you to do
more stuff but they make the levels more
difficult when they did Twin Snakes they
allow you to do more stuff like first
person point of view and everything they
didn't make the levels more difficult so
the gameplay was ten times easier oh you
know what I mean cuz of like I don't
know no I can aim it but I mean ya know
I wish we could talk about more part
four but unfortunately we didn't get a
catch hole there on to a snake is old
the part I played was cool yeah the part
that I saw was is hard but it was cool
it just meant under salt on those games
I know what I'm gonna start it I'm gonna
have to put aside everything like
Breaking Bad it's like breaking that
yeah well hopefully I understand this
road I think they divided par 5 into two
games oh yeah come on old movie on
you're saying oh and this is the one
that doesn't have David Hayter right is
that appointment that was the big issue
that's a big one I bounced it before
they were like David haters not gonna be
Solid Snake to David a [ __ ] crab battle
or no it's not so much dang it I I think
this game is about big boss or something
like that we'll see if we understand it
well I know my from run/walk this I'm
gonna just decide [ __ ] it's going to
dead them buy some video games
blood and gore intense violence sexual
sexual violence Mexico pasta life
she's being held for interrogation at a
camp on the southern tip of Cuba she's
nothing doesn't like metal gear huh hmm
need her on her side
we'll send a chopper from across the
Cuban corner yielding catches going solo
I like some a long time now
zeki for Sutherland oh it might be so I
stayed snake is so good
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
now that is badass yeah whoa
damn dude this is like gameplay yeah
this does look like gameplay
Chico where his posh she's dead
[Music]
how cool are you happy night-vision
goggles see this looks awesome
yeah it doesn't grant it looks back to
like Metal Gear Solid like us like a
more small location and stuff looks
smaller but more open like nice
whoa-ho damn really what in it
[Music]
but
who's that I have no idea I think that's
the point okay no that game does look
really [ __ ] cool regret I love how
the gameplay in the cinematic effects
actually look very similar yeah yeah you
know that Metal Gear has always been
pretty good about that at least since
they got on the ps2 and stuff yeah
that's true HiFi you have more okay yeah
I know the game doesn't really swim he
doesn't really show you much about what
it's like but I do love how it's going
back more to like the Metal Gear Solid
root of it all because there's like
metal sneaking and yeah it's like a real
sneaking mission you're more a victor
class being on it's it's an environment
that's like part three was like you're
in the [ __ ] jungle and then even part
two it's like yeah you're in one
location but it's like the most gigantic
location in the sky you're like a giant
tank and you're in some kind of like
middle of the sea like hell and this one
it's like I love that style like they're
invading a military base or something
like that yeah yeah exactly so it's like
small but still open so you really gotta
think about where you're gonna hide and
it's cool cuz I really promoted the
gameplay a lot of that one it wasn't
like I thought for like a Metal Gear
Solid they would just show us like more
cinematic stuff yeah cuz that's like
what they're really know important they
didn't do that though but and they show
us more the gameplay and they look like
they improved the gameplay too sweet
that's bad that's bad that's well worth
it I was already sold on this game
before I watched history or whatever
alright guys well if you're new to the
channel thanks for recommending that to
us by the way sure if you're new to the
channel subscribe do it right what the
hell Oh click the button subscribe right
maril got killed and shot that was like
I was really such a heavy there the
first time I saw that my heart was
breaking were there are no faces moving
ah my impression of first of all years
old just just expressionless people
moving their heads weird
shoutouts God crab battle
Xander Chamorro I'm still surprised you
shoutouts bro
sadly that's the rosen some people some
something wrong reasons some people
subscribe that's the reason no he said
reals and some people subcribe
okay all right anyway if I'm selling the
list and shout out to usual feed usual
fee I'm giving you a shout out
enjoy the shoutout eat it up chew it up
come on it do with it every more to do
to my shout out oh I was gonna say
Zander can take one for himself too
I don't know if you want to do on that
take one for myself
got it right right if Ron would call hey
Ryan
huge ran from England keep entertain us
don't want a shout out I want a high
five like it done I hope he had the good
timing on that's a high fiber screen
yeah you sound like you're from London
hello Mike cheerio
would you know what's more tight that
was like English and also southern boo
yo swore tight last one last one
Joshua more guiya shout out bro I love
your vids whoa bro I love your comments
what he does comments come polish I'm
sure someone's coming baby yeah tell me
I want that comment you tell me what
they callin they get that comment and
you put that comment in me yeah baby
yeah yeah use that common get right up
in there ah Oh comment
this is why I do shoutouts to make
people feeling good